so welcome to a special lecture
sponsored by the Global Health Studies
Program and the Gulf of justice
partnership
sponsored by the Yale School of Public
Health the Yale Institute for Global
Health the Yale Macmillan Centre Council
in African Studies the Yale Equity
Research Innovation Center the
Department of African American Studies
and the Salomon Center Health Policy in
law so I'm very excited today we're
gonna we're gonna run from now until
about 1:30 I know a lot of people have
to go to class at 1:00 and we'll take a
little sort of pause for you to leave
once that happens I'm very excited this
is our last advocates and residents
panel discussion that we've had as part
of the Global Health Studies program
this year and we're going out with a
bang it's a great panel we have today we
have the second tabouleh who is the
director of the Africa Center for AIDS
management at the University of
Stellenbosch in South Africa and the
former general secretary the treatment
action campaign and Jamila Headley who's
the managing director of health gap
you'll hear a little bit about their
stories which will flesh out their
biographies a bit but we're really going
to talk about the history the future of
global health today from two people who
are luminaries in the movement so this
is a celestial event two stars are
aligned in New Haven and I'm really
excited it's it's a thrill to have them
both here so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna start I'm gonna be the
moderator I'm not going to talk of just
ask questions and we're gonna start this
question so I thought we'd start the
story in 2008 I want to know where each
of you were about the time of the Durbin
AIDS Conference and to frame this in
terms of your introduction to the fight
for global access to at interpretive or
appeal and the fight for the right to
health where was I in 2000 definitely
not involved in any AIDS activism but a
year after that in 2001 it's the year I
found out about my HIV positive status
and it was right at the time when our
own president in South Africa was at the
peak of denying denialism
at the time when also true connection
campaign had a lot of support after the
debin AIDS Conference from international
activists and in other international
partners to support our cause in South
Africa and I think the Devon AIDS
Conference was really
Glenn mark would that brought different
allies from different perspectives to
see what was really happening in South
Africa because I mean their spotlight
was in South Africa because it was the
International AIDS Conference but it
gave us a lot of hope but we also got a
lot of resistance from day one would
have assumed that in 2000 after the
conference our president would have
changed his stance no he didn't and he
continued for many years after that and
we continue to fight and I think Debian
headed at its own moments but it also
was not just a a a winning moment but it
also was a reflective moment in terms of
how can people can come to conferences
and have all nice gatherings but at the
end of the day we were left with no
treatment where were you in well I was
15 so I was probably at summer camp
seriously in Barbados so yeah I was not
I was not yet in its fight but three
years later I ended up coming to the
United States and going to Vermont for
my undergrad degree at st. Michael's
College and I chose st. Mike's because
there was a professor there who was
really looking at the politics of the
global hiv/aids pandemic and and that
was Patricia salon at the time at home
in Barbados I had come into contact with
the crisis of HIV and Barbados we were
at the time the third highest prevalence
of HIV in the Caribbean region after
Haiti and Jamaica and in 2002 in
Barbados we started providing treatment
access for all the second developing
country after Brazil to do that and I
later found out in college that that was
in large part due to struggles that were
going on in South Africa and the profile
that was raised to lower the price of
HIV medicines for people all over the
world and that struggle that was being
waged by the second and other close
comrades now in South Africa 16 years
later in 2016 I found myself in Durban
again at a
another international hiv/aids
conference with a totally different
global reality to what there was in 2000
because of the work that activists did
to drive the price of medicines down to
say that it was unacceptable to have a
technology out there that was not
available to people who needed it most
and and was there with Lusaka at the
front of a march of the treatment action
campaign so for me 2,000 even though I
was in summer camp and I was a teenager
is is deeply embedded in my
consciousness as an activist and was an
important moment so we want to pivot to
the future but I I want to flesh out for
people who didn't live through this era
there's some people in this room who did
what those first years after the German
aids conference were like in terms of
you you were doing the priorities that
were being articulated and then we'll do
a fast forward into sort of a more
contemporary discussion there was a lot
of setting up and building the movement
and lot at that time we did a lot of
building popular education amongst
populations or even groups of people who
HIV and I was one of those that got to
learn about the global health issues
that related to access to medicine the
law I mean these were purely just the
people who were not even having an
undergraduate degree who suddenly had to
learn about trade related aspects and
learnt about connecting global health to
what was happening in South Africa but
also at the same time we had to
challenge our own government in terms of
its own obligations to deliver on human
rights which they felt this money and I
think 2003 we began to see that it was
possible that we would have a shift in
the government policy not because of
their own willingness we had we were
really at the peak of pushing and we
finally got a win we had our the South
African government announcing that we
were they will roll out antivirals in
2003 but it took another seven years to
actually have a real roll out so it took
the same activists who were there to
push for the policy to also make sure
that there's going to be implemented
we still struggle with the
implementation issues today but I think
one of the biggest thing that we are
very proud of is now there's new popular
cultures that have emerged out of our
work I mean wearing an hiv-positive
t-shirt is the coolest thing to do
whereas in 98 even at the time when I
was diagnosed in 2001 no one wanted to
wear the t-shirt so at least at the
level of affair of stigma and talking
about HIV
I think we've we've we've gone too far
but also at the level of people talking
about sexuality sex education and
empowering women to understand why
gender equality and power is at the
center of the AIDS discussion it's not
just something outside of that because
as you know in Africa the age of new
infections is in young women whereas the
age of mortality the a face of its
mortalities in men and there's an
interrelationship around the issue of
social gender norms so I think our work
began to really open up that
conversation which wasn't they the other
conversation was that people themselves
took power to themselves I mean the
power of knowledge that we had to read
this could reconstruct the relationships
between provider in in patients where
patients themselves were more powerful
than they provide I mean in many
instances some nurses didn't even know
how to treat for example I you know
whatever it's not a fungal infection
because they didn't have the medication
but we knew or the medication before
some of them knew they didn't know about
guidelines we knew about those
guidelines and how they should be
treating it so it helped us to have some
kind of leverage to negotiate with the
health system because there was a lot of
resistance the other element is that we
I think the biggest win at a global and
even at a national level is the fact
that we brought down drug companies to
their knees and many many economies
political economy is predicted we will
never do it it's not possible in a
capitalist environment and our
government was really pro-capital our
our fiscal policies were really probe
capital we will never
do it and now we say ha ha ha we did it
because now the price of drugs in South
Africa for first-line let me underline
for first line is one of the cheapest
but for second line it's not for third
line it so that's why we continue their
struggle but it's not the cheapest for
cancer drugs it's not the cheapest for
TB drugs so we seem to win some but we
don't have a groundswell of wind that at
least can have a knock-on effect on
other drugs because a person with HIV in
South Africa the level of co-infection
is at 70%
TB and HIV so you're winning HIV should
be able to have a knock-on effect on TB
or knock-on effect on on either diabetes
medication and so on so that's why we
continue to work so I think the issue of
monopoly and competition was one of our
biggest wins in life expectancy today or
people live with HIV in South Africa
it's almost the same as people who are
HIV negative
I can never predict it they thought
never it's not going to happen we are
just blowing a big horn by saying under
all antivirals will bring a big boost in
the health system we now have about 3.4
million people who are on antivirals who
are live contributing to the economy for
our own country including myself like
hit a lot of the highlights and I feel
like I came into this movement in 2003
at point where there were so many
exciting things unfolding as a result of
hard work and activism over many years
before that we in 2000 2003 we had the
creation of the President's Emergency
Plan for AIDS relief here in the United
States since then has become the single
largest source of funding for the AIDS
response around the world the creation
of a new kind of innovative mechanism
the Global Fund this idea that some sort
of global solidarity could redistribute
funds from wealthy countries to
countries that in the global South who
really needed those resources to fight
the three deadliest diseases came on to
the scene and what we saw when I was in
2003 I went for the first time to
Tanzania and at that point the streets
were so aligned with coffin-maker as the
scenes that everyone describes in East
Africa and Southern Africa at that time
of
people dying of people waiting to die of
coffin makers lining the streets that
was what I saw and two three years later
when I was going back to Tanzania again
that was completely shifting because of
this massive mobilization it was
unprecedented
we've never mobilized this much money
for a single disease before and for a
global response before and it wasn't to
be taken for granted like we had gone
decades with no investments right
decades with major inertia decades with
people saying that people in the global
South were too poor too illiterate to be
able to take the drugs right and that
transformation happened because people
really forced it to happen people
marched in the streets people put their
bodies on the line and really called for
that change to happen so we were at the
height of this this major shift and it
was exciting and as a student I was in
the United States at the time and
pressuring the United States
government's to do more and I see now
the Bennett you know the the
repercussions of that we have a five
billion dollar program a year coming
from the United States government around
the world now you know there are lots of
questions that's gonna be raised about
that and whether that's the that was the
best way to move forward but it was
certainly unprecedented and it saved
millions of lives around the world and
we get to see that every day in our work
now so I'm gonna start moving us forward
in the timeline in 2008 there's the
global economic crisis and a revival of
I'm not going to say rise everyone it's
a revival of the austerity economics and
there's a huge sort of slowdown in the
in at least
contributions to HIV programs
internationally so what was that shift
like after the sort of heady days of the
first part of that that decade not the
effects of the 2008 global financial
crisis I think many countries were
forced to look at their own domestic
health financing what what are the ways
in which countries can begin to think
about how to fund their own
HIV responses and activists really
pushed back on that narrative that look
we know that you avail in other sectors
why can't you bate health because health
is also an investment
and if you turn your backs away now
while we're halfway through their
response it's going to have really
negative effects on what you've already
achieved we began to shift our campaigns
to look at resources for health deeply
because we thought that one of the
things that we needed to make an
argument on is that one yes countries
should look at domestic health financing
we pushed for example it in the African
region for all the African countries to
look at what would be a percentage of
GDP per country that should we spend on
health and countries committed to a 15%
very few countries have even reached
that including my own country my own
country spends about 8% but still
there's there's a push from home by
activists for much more bigger
investment in health but also investment
in citizens but I think I think while we
did that it as activist it forces us to
look inward and not to look outward then
we take our eye away from you know
health as a global public good because
even those countries who are funding us
also have scaled back I mean the Global
Fund has a deficit as with then it won't
be able to raise all the funds that it
needs so we continuously are grappling
with the fact that there will not be
enough money to cover all the needs not
just HIV TB malaria diabetes cancer all
their health needs and where is the
money going to come from the other
second issue is the issue of obviously
the issue of human resources that they
we have very frail health systems and
the globe the economic financial crisis
also created a big brain drain where
people were moving away from conditions
that were worsening in their own
countries and went to wait wait was
better so it was not only their dollar
that also made the a challenge it also
had an impact in our health systems
because most of our countries I mean you
look at the as a Congo you look at
Malawi there's a high dependence on
external funding and that shift is not
happening very quickly where countries
are suddenly finding rends and crutches
to finance domestic health systems but
we still need a lot of support from
external while countries are
transitioning 20
closed domestic health financing yeah
it's really unfortunate that 2008 and
the economic downturn then was used I
think as an excuse yet to divest from
health global health from social
services and many other countries that
were going through economic hardships at
the time and that was a political choice
um after decades of neglect in the HIV
response we had finally started to see
glimmer of hope in 2003 with both lower
middle-income countries themselves
beginning to invest in the response and
wealthier countries beginning to give
massive amounts of development
assistance in just five years just five
years of progress that way we end up
with the global economic crisis and
while people found billions mm-hmm
trillions of dollars right to bail out
big banks right the argument was made
that because of the economic crisis that
people could no longer afford to give to
give as much global development
assistance and so we saw development
assistance from European governments
decline and from the United States
government what we saw was a flatlining
first initial cuts and flatlining in in
funding for the President's Emergency
Plan for AIDS relief and for the Global
Fund it's been devastating to see the
effects of this I think as a global
health community I think a lot of people
looked at that and said okay well how do
we get more efficient with what we've
got and there's been a lot of attention
paid over the last decade around how do
we make sure that we use those funds as
well as well as we possibly can and I
think that we're getting to the stage of
beginning to max out on some of those
efficiency gains like we can't we can't
stop this epidemic we can't end the
epidemic without more funding and yeah
and this economic downturn was used as
an excuse to stop that progress okay so
I'm gonna pivot to the sort of the
future and so post 2008 some people have
said that the model of financing for
global health in the response to HIV in
particular is unsustainable anyway you
know this is never going to work this
way what do you think about that
hmm we we all knew that that if a
vertical health financing is not
sustainable we know that but remember we
started from zero the the response at
country level including financial
investment in responding to HIV wasn't
they so we were just starting to show
that there is money in the world to
respond to HIV to respond to emergencies
such Amin with Ebola
we will fight we find them with them to
find money which people have claimed
that it doesn't exist but we do
acknowledge I think today we have to
have a conversation about how do we
bring all what we have to mainstream or
integrate to make sure that we at least
build our health systems to withstand or
be able to sustain it's our progress at
the moment in South Africa my experience
is that the HIV program is very fragile
because of a weak health system so you
can pump in money to support HIV but if
you don't have money to support health
care workers no money to buy x-ray
machines nor money to buy city for count
viral load machines it's it's you know
we are shooting ourselves in the foot
but who will find the health systems the
global leaders are saying that's not our
responsibility that's the responsibility
of the countries and you must make sure
that that happens for example we are
having a difficult conversation around
they're not introducing a national
health insurance but there's a lot of
pushback from big powers the private
sector doesn't want national health
insurance because its health has been
commodified let's be honest but once we
have a national health insurance it's
taking away medical schemes must go
private hospitals must go everybody must
get comprehensive health services now
suddenly rich people are going to be
standing in the queue with poor people
they don't want that so but at the same
time we have to push for a national
health insurance that can be able to
sustain their work that we've done there
is no shortcut but on top of it we still
need global health financing because
health is a public good what happens in
the US may also happen in South Africa
Robin South Africa will have an effect
in the u.s. so we can't say going
forward they
this is an easy way you dump all the
problems non communicable diseases will
will move between port will move across
borders because we all are eating really
sometimes crab food and we will have non
communicable health disasters and are we
going to say it's a problem of South
Africa the US won't get involved or UK
won't get involved I think we can't go
back in that conversation we have to
move forward in finding solutions that
can at least build resilient health
systems that are able to to to really
take care of all diseases not just HIV
because I I think we've been very
exceptional for a long time and I was
part of the extraction exceptional
movement when we put HIV HIV HIV but now
there is no HIV positive person South
Africa who does not need a health system
who does not need an S who does not need
a pap smear who does not need a checkup
once a year on TB so we can't continue
looking at HIV like that but how do we
use the resources generated from HIV to
be able to build a health system that
can take care of everybody I have to say
it's difficult I have to say I'm it's
such it really makes my blood boil when
I hear the like it's not it's just not
sustainable arguments right and and it's
made by like really well-meaning people
some people that I really respect
colleagues in the field that I really
respect and and I think a well-meaning
way right like everyone's concerned
about the drop off and donor funding and
everyone's concerned about what happens
next
but it makes my blood boil for two
reasons one I think that the current
state of affairs the current level of
inequality in healthcare access in
particular countries in the United
States for example in South Africa for
example and across the world that is
unsustainable
you know we I don't think the global
community can sustain a world in which
that level of inequality exists we
already seeing it in terms of populist
movements in terms of violence uprisings
in terms of you know kind of I just it a
world in which that is our reality
should be a non-starter for us it is not
sustainable if we really want to talk
about sustainability so that's the first
point and then the second
point is that implicit in this idea that
it's not sustainable is as rune
mentioned this idea that it's not our
responsibility to pay and and and that
somehow donors are doing a favor to the
global south or doing some sort of a
charity that that you're giving this it
completely ignores an entire history of
structural injustice from the wealthy
countries to inflict it on the global
South it completely ignores the argument
that I think AIDS activists were making
in the early days that I found inspiring
as a young activist was that they just
they weren't just saying you know help
these dying people one of the slogans of
health gap in the early days was drop
drop the debt treat the people donate
the dollars and the reason they had that
dropped the debt in there was because
they were calling for structural change
to the way that the global economic
system worked and the ways that it left
countries in a place where they could
not fund their health systems and where
they could not um that stopped these
epidemics from becoming crises so for me
I think there are two really fundamental
questions problems with this question of
sustainability and that we need to
completely call out the complete kind of
denialism
in those statements right and and come
up with different solutions right there
needs to be some form of I think some
form of global redistribution in order
to ensure health care for all globally I
don't see a path forward without that
let's start the conversation about that
and how we do that instead of talking
about sustainability can I add that by
the way there's a lot of out-of-pocket
payments done at household level that
many governments when they are talking
about the sustainability and thing about
finances that we are only thinking about
money coming from big coffers a lot of
households are still paying for health
care out of their own limited resources
depleted resources especially in
countries where if it user fees are
still imposed which needs to be
abolished also even in my own country
where you have two-tier health systems
where poor people are still paying for
medication not available in the public
health system who counts all of those
rains that are paid by poor people on
top of text on top of everything
that we are still asking domestic health
finance in domestic yes we agree
domestic house financing but there is
still a bigger conversation and I agree
with you about inequalities that are
driving this sustainability question I
mean for example it's totally ludicrous
to me that Jeff Bezos is worth 160
billion dollars multiple times more than
the health budget in many of the
countries in which many of us work and
live right it's just that that is
acceptable in our world is for me call
me an idealist right but like it's for
me just a non-starter it's something
that's got to change so you went there
and we'll keep going there so so the
global conversation about inequality
intersects with our conversation about
the future of global health and how do
you see how we deal in equality in South
Africa and Barbados in the United States
across the globe being tied up with the
future of global health I mean as I said
I think so much of the poor health
outcomes that we see in the world are
driven by economic inequality racial
inequality gender equality they're
deeply intertwined right and so when we
start moving beyond this idea of little
fixes like many of you how many people
in the room are public health right so
if you're a public health person you've
probably heard like the story of the
pulling the bodies out of the river
everybody heard that story you know and
like either we can pull the bodies out
of the river and and not think about why
they're falling into the river in the
first place
and fixing that and so a lot of what we
have been intervening where we've been
intervening so far I think is in pulling
the bodies out of the river from like
small fixes to reduce the price of
individual medicines but not fixing the
whole system of medicines pricing to aid
that's going to countries instead of
fixing the problem of countries not
being able to regulate their own
economies and being able to mobilize
enough government revenue to pay for for
health in their own countries when they
have natural wealth and natural resource
wealth
that could allow them to do that right
so I think we don't get too big fixes
around global health without getting too
big fixes around global inequality and
economic injustice and so you know how
we do that that's a source of debate but
like what would it look like for public
health professionals and schools to
begin thinking that way right so that
we're outside of the health sector now
we're talking about big fixes to the
global economic system so I think I come
from the country that has they well we
are labeled as the most unequal society
in the world I think there's a lot of
structural barriers that can be lifted
and I think our government sometimes are
too skeptical of rocking the boat I
think there's a lot of what in South
Africa today shouldn't be they there's a
lot of it that can be dealt with through
just regulation the Constitution in
South Africa allows for our government
to lift all of these barriers but it's
not been done because we are too nice to
capitalists and we are we just really
sometimes on care about our own citizens
and I have lived in a period where I
felt that my government was uncaring so
I'm feeling that it's uncaring now about
addressing equality in a tip tip tip way
so I think suggestions would be I mean
South Africa we have high unemployment
why do we continue to have an empire an
employment way we have a lot of wealth
in our own country we really have I mean
we still have a big mining industry in
South Africa why do we continue to have
unemployment I don't know we have a
skills shortage why do we have a skill
shortage amongst the most poorest people
who don't have the skills unemployed
unemployable because they don't have the
right skills our education our education
system is still in not in a good place
to produce enough so all of those things
are within what the government could
within the ambit of the government that
could change so there's all of that that
needs to be changed that has an impact
on healthcare healthcare is a
consequence of all those things that
they've not done that now we are create
3 creating another inequality in health
care because we have not addressed
economic
equality have not addressed social I
mean we have lots or there's a new
political part in South Africa the
economic freedom fighters basically
because people are feeling like we are
tired of looking at other people
progressing in life and we are stuck
where we were in nineteen sixty so for
me I think a really a radical discussion
with we talk about radical in a very
rhetoric way in South Africa it's red
everything is a radical but it means
nothing radical means you can just say
the radical weds and you take the Box
you are radical even my own government
so I think there has to be a deep
conversation in South Africa the one
that is not even about the ANC the one
that is about the people that says we
need to address once and for all in the
next five years these are the things we
need to do we need to abolish all you
know structural barriers for example
Cape Town has its own to your spatial
mess where poor people don't mix with
rich people just would by the way the
Cape Town is built Cape Town has people
who are cannot stay in certain places
for example in C Point C Point has no
social houses how can people be in the
same town and they cannot work in the
same city where they are where they are
their what they cannot stay in the same
city so those are some of the things
that I think we are dilly-dallying about
and therefore we think that health will
solve all of those problems so health is
pattern passed it's just adding more to
the mix do we have movements that's
another big question do we have
movements who are connecting all these
dots who are able to make sure that our
different waves of activism are leading
us to a better future I don't think so I
think we are very even the climate
movement is workaday environmental
health movements as well they are all
looking at climate change we are also
looking at health HIV access to meds
others are looking at something else we
need to at some point find ourselves a
common ground where we can come together
because we can't afford also these
pathways that seems not to speak to each
other if we can begin to do that I think
we will be in at the right track to
address deeply with the inequalities
including health because health is just
one lay out
and if we don't I mean what we know
already from from just a scientific
point of view is that we're gonna keep
having yeah I'm new diseases emerge
we're gonna have threats of potential
new pandemics in the future and this
again this will affect all of us right
no matter where you live you know we
look at the pandemics of flu we look at
the scares around Ebola and and ongoing
epidemic of Ebola in West Africa if we
don't intervene at the root cause here
we're gonna continue continue pulling
bodies out of the river so I want to
talk about leadership in the state of
leadership and HIV and global health
more broadly we just saw Michelle Saudi
Bay's last day after a huge sex candles
been scanned eliminates we see
leadership and rind in people like Bill
Gates the Gates Foundation what is
leadership look like moving forward it
certainly doesn't necessarily well it
certainly doesn't look like what we have
today or does it it's definitely yeah we
cannot look for leadership in the places
we used to look at urinates no derecho
no demuccio no I think we need to
redefine what kind of leadership is
needed to take us to where we need to be
by 2030 I think we have aspirational
goals that is leadership if if it is
that we still think that those you know
structures including UN aids or derecho
are still needed in order to drive us to
the right places
then it there needs to be a bit of a
reform in terms of what kind of leaders
do we want to be able to take us they
maybe some of those institutions needs
to go because if they are not able to
service or save what we need in this new
era then we have to part ways and
unfortunately I think UN AIDS is that
that that crossroad do we need UN AIDS
why we are talking about a much more
integrated thinking about health and
health inequality or health equity
other than having a in a a silo approach
and I certainly we are having this
conversation when UN aids as you are
saying it has been really in a very odd
position or in a very very awkward way
where I always thought that anyone who
who is an activist in HIV is has to be
aware about gender inequality and all
that comes with it
in 2018-19 for un aides to think that
they are a feminist organization and
then what happens and then they defend
it so it feels like we're going
backwards instead of going for so we
don't want that leadership and we we've
said that clearly we do not want that
leadership and people can want to wear
all nice suits but that time is over we
need leadership that really can't think
deeply about the inequalities in an
intersectional way we can't afford to
have an AIDS movement that does not look
at gender equality we can't afford that
because then we are moving backwards we
have was going to come back and address
the gender inequality of not addressed
we are even saying that in our own
political parties in South Africa that
no longer the days where people are
saying yes is the political struggle but
wait with your feminism no feminism
first and then anything else because we
have been putting forward backwards a
lot of issues around sexual reproductive
health women's equality at the back foot
and it's coming to haunt us it's voting
after the AIDS movement deeply because
we didn't we didn't do we didn't do very
well now we have an opportunity to to be
very intentional about intersectionality
and that's the kind of leader I want I
want a leader that's able to articulate
inequality from broad spectrum not just
from one view because then you are
missing an opportunity with I mean we
get a lot of airtime as leaders you are
wasting at time if you just going to be
talking about one issue and you we get a
lot of you know what is invitations to
important spaces it's an opportunity to
make the linkages we also get a lot of
space to to build movements and
communities why do we want
strip people into different sections if
we can go into a community and build a
movement why not to bring all the health
elements in that conversation and I
think that's the type of leader from
different levels of leadership not just
they because for me I think there's no
leadership day there's a lot of
leadership on the ground people are
really trying to figure out these things
that local level there's nothing that
pulls us together at a global level
because we see what's happening
I mean people now are in it for their
own Seavey's they are in it for their
own budgets it now the biggest break of
them all is how much money you've raised
you know all sorts of things that never
used to be matter today they are and
we've become much more faker and faker
as we as the inequalities are increasing
so I think we need to instant respect a
bit and maybe do you want to come back
and I mean because some of us are
sitting in in comfortable positions in
academia right so I was going to with
who's going to be the leader although we
suck I have to say that our leaders
probably don't look like Greg and
they're probably not white men wearing
suits okay
frankly I don't think that's what the
future of global health leadership needs
to look Yeah right like when I'm just
thank me later but but you know when we
look at the leadership in global health
right now the reality is you know
they're the people that we see out front
ahead of UN aids ahead of WTO they're
the people who are a little less visible
the Bill Gates the door sir says that
the people behind the scenes right like
who are funding much of the work that
happens in global health the people and
and that's who's leading right now yeah
and I don't think that these actors are
capable necessarily of addressing or
leading the kind of structural big fixes
not tiny fix change that we need to see
in global health right as we second
saying the leaders probably probably
look like the activists who are on the
ground in several of these countries and
the question is how do we help that
floor
Chowdhury helps that rise to the floor
because I think that's the only way we
can to change you know many of these
actors have benefited from this global
economic system this very system that
have has exacerbated the health outcomes
you know poor health outcomes for the
for for the for the poor many of these
people who are leading in global health
are the same ones who have benefited
from from those systems right so how can
we expect them to dismantle them and so
when we think about leadership in global
health it's got to look really different
than what we have right now if we want
to achieve the kind of change that at
least I dream of so we have one more
question we're gonna open it up for
discussion and and your questions to be
second Jamila so often when we talk
about global health the conversation is
among predominantly Western audiences
talking about how to solve the problem
of poor access to health care and for
people living in low and middle income
countries but here we have our own
daunting problems with inequality and
access to health care world of good what
could we learn from South Africa from
Barbados and the rest of the world here
in the US well I mean the u.s. is like
astounding to me it's remarkable that 80
mil you know 80 million people in this
country are paying off how struggling to
pay off haven't cared that it's
remarkable that despite spending so much
money on health care health outcomes in
this country you mean so poor so I feel
like there is a lot that that that the
United States could take notes from the
rest of the world on in terms of how to
do health care right I come from a
really tiny country I come from Barbados
and Barbados and in the 1920s Barbados
had some the worst health outcomes of
any of the British colonies it's
well-documented in kind of colonial
documents in history we had them some of
the highest maternal mortality rates and
the highest infant mortality rates and
by the late 70s we had completely turned
that situation around we ended up with
some of the lowest child mortality and
maternal mortality rates in the region
and of developing countries around the
world and the question is how did we do
it
now like there's no one magic bullet but
I think that there's some things that
are really instructive for the United
States and for for people elsewhere one
we allocated a tremendous amount of our
public expenditure
health care at the height of kind of a
bar push on health care we were
allocating between 25 and 30 percent of
our of our government budget to
transforming the health sector so that
was one but money is not enough as we
know in the United States lots of money
in health care not fixing the problem we
invested heavily in primary health care
and basic health services not
necessarily disease-specific not waiting
for people to end up in hospital but
treating people you know I'm prevent
providing preventive care for people and
then the third thing which I think is
really really remarkable and gets to my
question of structural change is that
Barbados was one of the few countries
that resisted IMF intervention at a
point in the 1970s and 80s when the IMF
was going and dismantling social
programs all over the world in the
global south there was actually a major
major kind of remarkable story of
Barbados that we don't have time for
where we resisted that intervention and
so we managed to stave off what I see is
some of the structural instruments that
have been used to kind of prepare and of
fuel poor health care poor health
outcomes around the world and so I think
there's a lot that's instructive about
that we need structural big fixes we
need to invest in primary health care
and a basic health systems and we also
need to have an invest enough to make to
transform the health systems around the
world mm-hmm
I think I mean to add to that there is
the political will in the Western
countries to acknowledge that universal
health care is a right I think that that
starts from day and if it is not
acknowledged that way what other tools
or frameworks or avenues that can be
used by US citizens to affirm themselves
and their voices if it's not in the
Constitution where else can we find text
or subtext that people can use to
organize to drive that political will if
it doesn't exist I don't know how can a
poor person in the u.s. pay three times
more for a drug that is five dollars in
South Africa I don't know how that makes
sense for a drug from a cow drug company
who sells it in the US for three times
more the price that it is in it
it is in South Africa that for me is
cruel it's cruel at many levels it's
cruel because it's allowed in the
country and how is this how is that
allowed because you know health equality
is a right for everybody and everybody
should have the same access or same
right to live like everybody else not
just those who are in of course there's
a little bit of feeling feeling guilty
about what they did in Africa there's a
lot of that and sometimes we do use that
let me be honest we do use that and pull
that string but that is not an excuse
for people in their own countries not to
be able to have access to health care
and for us we use the Constitution where
we could it has its own limitations and
if it's possible lawsuits if that is
possible if not I think we have to find
ways in which we can find some text that
really can help people in those
countries where they don't have they
don't have access to health care today I
think the conversation we have about
national health insurance comes from the
times when the ANC wanted to be in power
they promised us a free health care
right in 1994 and we are bringing that
conversation now saying you promised us
free health care you didn't promise that
the health care that is funded by PEPFAR
or funded by global fund you promised us
healthcare funded by our own state
because we you have a duty to us as your
citizens so I think sometimes those
conversations are needed at country
level but I really I don't have it one
size fits all for countries that I don't
really know what's the situation in
terms of human rights and what what you
know what led to is the end on and is it
a constitutional leg or is it what else
that is available that you people can
use other avenues one thing that I've
learned from South Africa is the
importance of people power and the
importance of patients people who are
affected there's a there's a view that
sick or disabled or people need someone
to advocate on their behalf and that's
not true at all right like and and so so
movements powered by people who suffer
at the hands and cruel and cruel is
exactly the right word cruel systems of
injustice and oppression are so
important and and the hardening thing is
right now in the United States today
we're kind of seeing that around
medicare-for-all
we're seeing people who are poor who are
sick who are struggling to pay their
health care bills who are struggling to
provide for their families in the midst
of chronic diseases and other challenges
they're rising up and I'm I'm excited to
see what's going to happen as a result
so I want to open it up for questions
from the audience it the mic is here
because we're recording for people who
are not in the room so raise your hand
I'll come over and you can speak in the
mic and Paseka and and Jamila can ask
questions just say who you are and where
you're from
hi I'm Christina Talbert Schlegel I'm
from the Yale School of Medicine in the
Global Health Studies Program thank you
so much this has been amazing I wanted
to ask your thoughts as we see countries
including the United States moving much
more toward this isolationist
nationalist leadership structure what
are your thoughts on that for global
health in the future of global health
generally and then what should be the
narrative around that like should there
be a framing that's more national
security or some kind of what should be
the narrative around that or should
there be a narrative around that to to
address this trend yeah that's super
concerning and perhaps as an
organizational priority for us right now
health gap has become thinking about US
leadership in 2020 and what will happen
there because we just we see the future
of global health doesn't look so bright
if we continue on this isolationist path
and and we think it will be very
damaging for global health what should
be the narrative like I personally don't
think the global health security I find
the global health security lens deeply
problematic in many ways I think it
dehumanizes people I think it continues
to feed into militaristic kind of
Lenz's about how you approach the world
and again it's feeding this narrative
that I think is part of the system that
we need to dismantle I am increasingly
curious about making the argument of how
unsustainable the level of inequity is
in many on many planes right like not
just in terms of our security here in
the West but but but in terms of
economic stability and in terms of all
the planes that we can think of right
making making that argument about the
need to support human thriving
everywhere right and how integral that
is to our political stability to our
economic stability and and to our future
generations to the folks to the survival
of our species in the sets right like
you know we have to think about climate
change and health we have to you know so
I'm interested in trying to weave that
argument and I think we I don't think
the public health and I would just this
weekend doing some searching around the
literature around this I don't think
that our public health community has
done enough work to like do the modeling
around that to do the argument around
that to bring the evidence of that to
bear and I'd love to see much more done
on that in the future but I'm really
scared about the isolation and it's not
just to unite the United States all over
Europe and and and it's gonna drive the
next if if we have the next major
disease outbreak yeah in this kind of
context like that's terrifying to me so
I think for me I don't know if there's
any good story that comes out of
isolation we live in a global society
leaders thought that was the best idea
so they must just live with it
unfortunately they are going backwards
for all sorts of reasons nationalistic
is one big issue but I can't foresee how
how would you isolate the u.s. from the
rest of the world and what could be the
consequences some of them would have
will be negative for the u.s. one I mean
for research let me pick one thing
research a lot of the health research
collaborations or whatever we can think
of happens with other parts of the world
where we understand some of the things
and nuances that we may not be able to
know if we only looked at the US only
and we come up with really good modern
science medication products out of that
is the u.s. prepared to go in isolation
and with the consequences that isolation
will mean that you can trade with other
countries you will trade with yourself
you if there is such a thing where you
trade with yourself you you can't also
do research collaboration which then
means that it limits the opportunities
in the future to have new products to
look at new diseases and how you treat
new diseases if you are not able to try
out in different context is the u.s.
prepared to do that the other part is we
many of us outside your borders are also
contributing to the u.s. public health
because as some of our nurses and
doctors and scientists work here are you
going to close your borders for them to
end students who are coming to the u.s.
for cross-border Lenny and u.s. students
who are going to South Africa in many
other countries for cross-border
learning is the u.s. prepared to only
know one view of the narrative and it's
prepared that's how it wants to I don't
think that's a good idea
it's bad in many ways and yes it comes
from a military point of view which I
don't know where it has ever wet because
Israel is the worst-case scenario if
that's it's being inspired there then I
think we we have we're heading for a
disaster for us as activists we have to
push back in that narrative because
globalization has yielded so much better
solidarity for us we would not I for
example Greg and many other activists
and healthcare in Ekta were able to see
our situation in South Africa with their
own eyes that it would have been very
difficult for us to articulate our
suffering without people actually seeing
our suffering because it's very easy not
to understand because we don't see it's
very easy for us not to understand that
Venezuelans are dying today of diseases
that are preventable because we tend to
prevent to pretend
we pretend not to see but when you see
it there's no way you can undo what
you've seen so I think for activists for
us global globalization is good because
it builds solidarity it builds
transnationalism that has really helped
us to work together on really important
issues and difficult grappled with
difficult issues the issue of access to
medicine is one of the biggest example
of what how globalization can really
work also to build movements in that way
so I don't know how this can be a good
story other questions here hi my name is
Kay I'm a student at the School of
Public Health here I was interested in
what you were saying about how
capitalism doesn't work you know won't
we think about global health and stuff
so what do you think is the role of
things I public/private partnerships and
entrepreneur approaches to global health
things like social impact bonds stuff
like that
socially in public entrepreneurial
approaches social impact bonds you
talked about the relation between
capital and global health what do you
think of other sort of things like
entrepreneurialism social impact bonds
etc we're talking about wide variety of
things I I mean I have my own like kind
of strong views about privatization and
home care and so where entrepreneurship
is used as a code-switch for for private
I private an increased role of private
companies and corporations in providing
health care I don't know that that's the
best way for for many of the people in
the world and and but I do think we need
entrepreneurship and we need like we
need people creating and innovating
around how we dismantle some of these
big structural kind of barriers to
improving the health for people around
the world and how we better deliver
health healthcare right so I don't know
if that answers the question but I feel
like it it's case by case you know like
I mean I have you know some concern
about the rise of private engagement and
that the fact that even around the
universal health coverage or universal
health care push that so much of it has
become a conversation about private
private companies providing health care
in the private insurance industry I
think I mean I I'm with you they that
they my my stance is that health is not
a commodity it is something that the
state is responsible to provide to its
citizens if it decides to outsource
certain parts of its services that is
it's a responsibility our interaction or
interface is between the citizen and the
state because the problem is with all
these other enterprises their
responsibility when health care is not
delivered is D fed to the provider not
to the state and the state says that was
not my responsibility when they ran out
of drugs it's because it recombinant did
drug company did not stock up enough
medication whose problem is that because
they I have a social contract
between me and the state I don't have a
social contract with an innovator with a
social a partner so I think once we get
to a conversation where we allow too
much of a mix where 80% of Health Care's
provided by external partners we have a
serious problem because then that state
is not taking any responsibility for
health care all and not taking
responsibility for engaging with its
citizens when the citizens are
complaining it does not see those
complaints as the complaints against
them its system is complaints against
that private partner so but I'm not
saying there's no space because we have
to live with the fact that we are living
in a capitalist world but there is a
space for private for private companies
but it's just that fundamentally we care
I cannot agree with health as a
commodity fundamentally so then that
means that I do not want my service
provision for health care I don't want
to interact with a private company I am
interacting with my government and Mike
when I complain I'm complaining to my
government I'm not complaining to a
service provider who cares no you know
nothing who doesn't care anything what
what what do I say so because we have
that mix in South Africa it's very
tricky we have a private health care
system which is appalling in its other
ways but also still it gives us a
specialized health care but we need
basic comprehensive services for people
and then you can top up and go and buy
those specialized services if you want
their state must be responsible the
comprehensive services so that everybody
has the same right to receive the same
services from the state and anything
else you want to buy that's on top of
that go and buy somewhere else but we
are paying money to the state to give us
this and we are not paying money to a
private provider to give us something
else so I think fundamentally I can't
agree to a role play a big role played
by private private health care
my name is Kaylie Bechtold I work at the
School of Public Health in the global
health Leadership Initiative I have a
specific question about the universal
test and treat and how you align that in
South Africa being that it shows that it
improves health outcomes yet the health
system may not be ready for it and so as
an activist where do you place yourself
knowing that okay you could support
universal tests and treat but that
people's lives might be lost in the
middle there because the health system
is not ready for it but knowing that if
you don't support it then you could have
not as good of health outcomes as you
know you could have yeah I'm currently
supporting 28 linux in the city of Cape
Town I am struggling with that I'm
asking myself did we shoot ourselves in
the foot as activists by agreeing to
this or did we agree too quickly because
we yes we agree but people are not ready
to start a RT and and we have been asked
by providers so make them ready you all
asked for this make sure that they said
and yes then we convinced them to start
and then people fall out because they
are started too quickly there is no
support system I mean PEPFAR in the last
round didn't support community health
workers and this in this round in cop 19
yes there is a lot of financial support
to employ people who can track I am
grappling with that I think there is no
right or wrong answer we don't need a
lot of people to start treatment because
a lot of people are still dying today in
South Africa why there's access to
treatment because they don't know their
status but the health system is not
coping because the numbers are way too
too big for the health system to cope
that's why I started off in the
conversation that our health system is
very fragile it needs to be resilient
enough for it to really make sure that
universal test and treat is meaningful
at the moment it's not we're getting a
lot of pushback from facility-level were
saying we don't have capacity we they
even say that they for example they will
start them on treatment but who's going
to follow them up was right now we are
turning people into numbers there's
a lot of dehumanizing happening with you
TT because of the fact that people are
now saying yes number 20 number 15
number hundred we no longer are people
because you just wants to make sure that
you pop the PD in every person who comes
in the clinic and what happens after
that you have 70% lost to follow-up it
it one facility member so I'm really
concerned about that because it also is
it can also you know be a bad reflection
on our own activism but at the same time
we are not the ones who must make sure
that the system works their state must
do its part they also agreed to
universal test entrance
they should have calculated how the
system was going to absorb so many
people in the health system that's why
we go back to the state that when you
said new guidelines you TT you knew that
this was happening so but we use that to
push the system to be able to cope with
bigger numbers because the realities
that people are going to die if they
don't start treatment so it's a
difficult balance I have two things to
say on this our history at the movement
the HIV movement makes us very wary of
anyone who says that you shouldn't get
the technology science progress to poor
black people around the world right for
many many years it was said that people
who were in the global south would take
AR T badly or poorly that they couldn't
take the drugs and that delayed not
delayed the kind of progress that we
needed to see so with tests and treat it
was very much I think for many of us the
same reaction like you know there are
real questions about capacity yeah but
but there's also this history on this
legacy of saying that both these people
aren't ready they can't handle it right
like so let's not make sure that they
get the thing that we know that will
improve their health outcomes the most
my argument here is that it is true we
knew when we were talking tested treat
that it needed to come with massive
investment in the health system that
they needed to come with community
health workers that it needed to come
with proper support it hasn't come with
that that's why it's feeling yes not
feeling because we push for it too soon
it's failing because it's lacking the
investment that it needs to for us to do
it properly
and we need to you know and not just
money investment but the will yes
the health systems and the ways that we
know work best for people living with
HIV so I I kind of refuse except that
you know and I and for people like GUI
psychic who are on the frontlines of
overseeing clinics who are providing
they have to grapple with this
differently from the way that I get to
grapple with it as an activist who's
arguing for the shifts and resources and
and and that we think is needed to to
provide universal treatment access
properly in a thoughtful way but I do
think we have to continue to push for
everything that we need to provide care
in the best possible way and that
includes beyond the health sector why
are people defaulting from treatment you
know I was recently in Haiti where again
like for every you know two or three
people that we put on treatment one
person's being lost to follow up right
in this era of tests and treat why
because once people start to feel well
they don't have jobs they go and they
migrate to to Dominican Republic or
wherever where they don't have health
care they come back when they're really
ill or because many of the programs have
been slimmed down so much to providing
more and more people with initiating
more and more people on treatment so
they're no longer providing the kind of
social support and safety net that we
know is necessary for people living with
HIV anywhere in New York if you're a
person living with HIV you have access
to housing support you have access to
all sorts of other social services and
safety net that come around treat okay
the drugs it's not just the medicines
not just the pill so I think that we
need to continue to be demanding a
response that includes everything we
know that it's needed to provide good
health care to people did you ever hi
I'm Gerry friedlin I'm at the school of
medicine a work in South Africa
prescribed antiretrovirals and TB drugs
and have been doing it for 20 years and
here and there were more similarities
and differences in terms of this the
effectiveness of the systems and and
slow way in which government responds to
needs and inequities and it's I think
it's less forgivable here than it is in
South Africa which still is a poor
country even though it's rich
I wanted to affirm the issue of
expanding the healthcare system by using
community health care workers and not
the traditional ways in which people are
cared for but actually this strength in
communities that still exist
particularly in the for example the
rural area where I live and work or work
and we have these health care systems
are still pretty traditional they rely
upon traditional professional workers
and for some of the issues that are
important in terms of keeping people and
care you really don't need a nurse you
need someone to be with them in their
community and support them and that can
be a community health care worker and so
there's an underutilized huge population
of people who could be employed and
useful in the health care system just as
an aside but I affirm very much that
that's one way of strengthening the
health care system now I'm standing here
I'm I wanted to make a comment that you
all know but it's big in this room and
we it's sort of like a giant balloon and
that's our own political system and the
Jeopardy that our political system and
our leaders now but both to us and what
we believe in and also to the rest of
the world so one of the things we all
really need to do in the next two years
is make sure that our current political
system disappears and as activists as
traditional more traditional people like
myself I see that as a really important
issue that affects global health and our
own health so working in the political
system really to to make sure that our
current administration is defeated I
think is a central goal to maintain and
to improve our public health I don't
think you're gonna argue with that
questions questions
oh he's good over here
I'm I'm Aiden I'm an undergrad doctor
Dougal I'd love to hear you speak more
to the strategy in the fight against
drug companies to lower the first line
first line arity and what it looks like
to expand that okay so we we use
different strategies one was okay was to
ask the states to use whatever legal
framework that we have available for
example the use of compulsory licenses
to apply for a particular drug that was
cheaper in another country to apply for
it to be available in South Africa but
we had no political way so our Minister
of Health was not going to do that so we
then broke the law in as part of our
civil disobedience campaign we went to
Thailand and looked for a cheaper drug
that was expensive in South Africa and
brought it back in South Africa which
created a lot of who were with with
Pfizer because they were charging this
price the like 10 times more than what
the price was of a generic version of
the same drug in in Thailand but that
helped us to push Pfizer to a position
of either dropping the price or creating
competition for another generic company
in South Africa to provide a cheaper
version of that drug that's another way
of doing it the other way was to take
some of the track companies that refused
to give voluntary licenses to generic
manufacturers we took them to a
competition tribunal to show how they
were profiteering in overcharging for
drugs in South Africa while we had the
public health crisis where in other
countries they they there was a cheaper
vision but they wouldn't allow general
manufacturers to compete with them in
the same space but with a cheaper drug
we won we won that case in the
Competition Commission for example for
for nevirapine with pouring out we've
also for AZT with GlaxoSmithKline then
and which led to many more drug
companies to come in the market to
compete for those drugs because they
were forced as part of the judgement of
the competition come
to have negotiations with it with the
general generic manufacturers to
negotiate a voluntary fee that was
reasonable so that the price is not
ridiculous so that even the drug the
generic manufacturer becomes much more
expensive because they have to pay for
the voluntary fee their voluntary
license fee those are some of the
examples there are other examples where
again I mean at an individual level when
you go in and ask for example
out-of-pocket as for a generic which was
something that the general public never
knew there was a difference we never
knew that the actual you can ask for a
cheaper drug off the off shelf there's
their options and the generic is cheaper
we didn't know even what was the
difference between a generic and a
counterfeit so we're able to even resist
the the move that Sternin general sorry
brand drug Big Pharma also influenced
the public by saying generics are paired
they're counterfeit everything is
counterfeit I mean in in in Kenya and
other countries there's been a lot of
pushback to say no you can't include a
RV's in this entire virus in the same
penguicon
as counterfeit we know what is
counterfeit and we know what's the
difference but don't include these drugs
because these drugs have been FDA
approved they they have been a whole
sorts of evaluations of this drug so you
can't do that so we did all sorts of
those campaigns as a result we have a
big a large generic manufacturing
companies in South Africa competing
fairly and healthy with other with with
Big Pharma there's that doesn't mean the
fight is over they they have their own
fights but we in we sometimes do
negotiate with drug companies and say we
know that there's a new drug for example
Dorota gravi we know that there's a new
drug coming it's much better I'm not
saying the lithography is better with
everything it has its own challenges
like any other track and I'm not a I'm
not going to I'm not advocating for just
one track but I'm just saying an example
so we would go to drug companies that
have that that can sell the truck and
ask them how much and why are you
charged in that price as activists so we
can in engage track come
directly we went on a visit in Thailand
over a period not Thailand in India over
a period of three weeks to look at all
generic manufacturers and what kind of
drugs were in the pipeline so that we
know by the time they're depositing at
OC and South Africa we know that there's
a drug coming in South Africa and it's
going to do then we start pressuring the
medical control console from our end to
say we know that there's a drug that's
been sitting in your shelf and you have
not been reviewing why are you waiting
what are you waiting for so you can use
multiple ways and it seems to have
worked and we again all these things
that we did we learned them from other
countries we went in from Brazil we
learned from conference in Thailand we
learned from other other companies who
have tried different ways and we've
tried to do a some kind of a mix of
ideas in in strategies in South Africa
and just to say like in addition to what
was happening in South Africa activists
elsewhere around the world where a
Pfizer and these other companies had
their headquarters we're also using
direct action and yes using protests and
using confrontation using the media to
to confront them on the issue of pricing
so yeah it's such an again an incredible
story of transnational kind of influence
and and coordination among activists
that remarkable and is still happening
on many other issues today there's a lot
of work going on around the price of
premium right now and again like we're
seeing some of the same activists and
some new ones arise to kind of tackle
that issue now
I'm Raphael Paris Escamilla from the
Yale School of Public Health
and you mentioned Brazil and Brazil is
an example of the country that thanks to
the fact that the Constitution included
the recognition of the right to health
care allowed a low-income woman in Rio
de Janeiro who had HIV to actually sue
her government because she could not
have economic access to the medication
and that was the beginning of a huge
universal and retroviral a very
successful movement in Brazil so I
wanted to ask you to please comment on
whether overall the global experience
tells us if it makes a difference when
countries recognize in their
constitutions that right to access to
health care or is priscila an exception
and it doesn't really matter that much I
can speak from our experience in South
Africa our Constitution section 27 does
recognize the right to health further
even sexual reproductive health that
people should have access at the point
of care but a constitution is the
Constitution it is it means nothing
without the people because you can have
the right to health in the Constitution
but how do you translate that into
reality of people it must still be the
same activists who must make that a
living Constitution because we had to
take that that section 27 and make it a
reality
an example is the our government knows
that there's a section 27 David UT to -
to the right - an obligation to make
sure that people have progressive
realization of the right to health but
we've seen redress in rigorous in
certain areas and we are able to go back
but without us continuously being
vigilant where is the state not able to
progressively realize that right and go
back to the court where the court says
yes the state has done something wrong
the state was wrong but at the end of
the day it's a judgment and the judgment
can end up being a judgement if there
are no people who are taking that
judgment and making it
elet enforcing it to become police
enforce eager to become operational
plans to become a budget and so on so it
still needs you yes you have that you
need the Constitution because at least
it gives you a framework but you still
need the people who take that framework
and make it a reality so that people can
actually live who have enjoyed good life
and quality life because of the
contrition end because people are able
to take that Constitution so I think a
combination works but not one or either
I would argue I'm not sure if it is
either necessary or sufficient and I'll
give context for what it's certainly not
sufficient as we second saying like it's
not sufficient to have it in the
Constitution with nobody pushing you to
to realize that right into and
challenging when it's not realized but
you know I come from a country where we
do not have the right to healthcare
explicitly in our constitution it's not
your concern for me because I I see the
Constitution as a fail-safe almost like
a way to challenge if if there is
regression and we don't have that right
to challenge right now explicitly in our
constitution but yet invested tremendous
amounts in health care transformed a
health story from one that was a dire
and abysmal record of health outcomes to
one that was one of the best in the
region without a constitutional
instrument driving that but with a
really strong social compact yeah
and social contract between newly
elected black posts independent black
government and its people driving that
so I'm not sure whether it's necessary
or sufficient yeah yeah
you have room for one more question
thank you my name is Bob block I've got
a background in economics and sociology
I remember about twenty-five or thirty
years ago in East European intellectual
spoke at Yale advocating a Marshall Plan
for Eastern Europe and my comment to him
was that I was very sympathetic but also
skeptical and I said to him that a
Marshall Plan consists of two parts
you know one is the plan and the other
is the resources if he had a really good
plan he would get the resources but if
he did not have a really good plan he
would not get the resources so I think
if we could come up with something that
you know makes it you know a big
difference it works well and makes sense
and that benefits both the developing
countries and the and the donors then we
might you know have a better opportunity
for a better result so we have about
three minutes left I'm gonna give you
guys a chance to say closing comments
few seconds here by the way from May
11th Jamila's going back to Puerto Rico
[Music]
so any final comments in both of you
don't feel compelled yeah hmm I think
when I I'm I'm but I'm still wanting to
go back to one issue the issue of unison
Universal testing treat then I I get I
get your your view
jameelah that yes we have to push back
because we know that Universal testing
it works when it has the resources when
it has resilient health system it works
and we do deserve that from all over the
world and if you come down to reality
it's a complete opposite of that so I
think that's why a lot of us who are
either old active
I don't know what to call myself yeah
okay
old activists who are now finding
ourselves in the middle in the middle
that you get a clinic that says okay you
guys said this works yes we know it
works
show us how it works and then I think a
lot of us struggle with that because I
think it'll ever where they are no
resources what can I show because I know
that the government has not given enough
boost and support to make universal
tests and treat the best of what it
could be because they are no they have
not given those resources so I
completely agree with you
but there is also a lot of no there's no
political will to absorb community
health workers in South Africa let's be
honest and they've been saying that for
10 years that years who absorb and then
they decide it's going to be twenty
thousand two thousand one date one
thousand and we have two governments
literally we have the answer governor of
the ta government I live in the province
where the DA will not support the
national health insurance they are
saying they have their own alternative
what happens with universal tests and
treat in a province where the government
or the political party does not support
what we think is the resource mechanism
both financial and human will support
that but we're still part of South
Africa we're not an island in South
Africa so it's it's complicated and I I
agree with you I am NOT for let's look
at what is the reality and therefore
let's let's make ourselves not only
infinity find by that but the balance
between when we are asked to support as
activists what do we do how do we step
in with the reality of the nests on the
ground because those are my allies the
doctors were prescribing every day are
my allies and when they say for example
ask to help in this with akley's I had
no idea how bad things were and now I'm
grappling with absolutely I think there
needs to be a campaign to make sure that
this thing works because it's being said
to fail there are no resources at local
level so I agree with you so yeah it's
just that implementation is complicated
I think one of the hardest things from
me someone working as an activist in
this field is this balance between
pragmatism and the reality of where we
are at with all of the history of
structural injustice and everything that
led us here the mess of like kind of
private interests and kind of injustice
that led us to where we are now and you
know how do we remain pragmatic in that
context and also how do we continue to
have imagination about what the world
should be one the role that I think we
should be playing as activists it's a
creative role like I see my work as
deeply creative work my role is to
imagine a world that doesn't yet exist
we have not seen a world where there is
universal access to health care where
all people can access regardless of
their race gender you know Association
AMA quack round we don't we've never
seen that before we don't know how we
don't know what that looks like really
yeah maybe of us we don't know what it
feels like we don't know how to get
there you know part of our role is to
imagine that and and one of the things
that we need from the next generation of
public health warriors in this field is
imagination like you
we can't just remain in the pragmatic
because then we don't get to the big
fixes that we need and part of the
inspiration for me that my inspiration
on maintaining some sort of creativity
in my work and some sort of imagination
and throwing out wild crazy ideas like
let's like think about what global
redistribution could look like you know
I get that inspiration from AIDS
activists like through CEQA and you know
Zakir and Greg and all of these people
who went before me because they imagined
a world where the price of ARVs was
$20,000 a year and they imagined that it
could be a fraction of that price it was
unimaginable to many many people and
then they did it they made it happen so
you know I think we need to maintain yes
we work in this reality of this worlds
where we need to be pragmatic and where
we need to address like this in-between
where we are at where we're trying to
advance access to services but the
reality is we're starting from a
that's so low but we've got to keep that
keep holding on to the to the thing that
we can imagine doesn't yet exist and
should so I want to thank the second
Jamila for being here today can we give
him a round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]